[Música]
japón se despidió de los juegos
olímpicos con récord de medallas de oro
y récord de contagios de ccoo y 19 en
medio de críticas tokio espera el
comienzo de los juegos paralímpicos en
dos semanas mientras parís se prepara
para ser la sede de las justas en 2024
el grupo talibán sigue ganando terreno a
medida que las tropas internacionales se
retiran de afganistán ya tiene el
control de cinco capitales de provincia
y el gobierno asegura que éstas se
convertirán en las tumbas de los
insurgentes el portavoz talibán asegura
que el gobierno decidió declarar les la
guerra
hicieron apocalípticos en la isla griega
de eubea miles de personas han tenido
que ser evacuadas mientras las llamas
abandona alimentadas por las altas
temperaturas fuertes vientos y baja
humedad la ayuda internacional está
siendo clave para grecia que está
sufriendo la peor ola de calor en tres
décadas
gracias por acompañarnos en una nueva
emisión de noticias en france 24 soy
marina colorado
tokio se despidió de unos juegos
olímpicos inusuales marcados por las
restricciones de público y las medidas
de bioseguridad por la pandemia de ccoo
y 19 el presidente del comité olímpico
thomas bach afirmó estar orgulloso de
esta competición que considera una
muestra de solidaridad y paz
la antorcha ahora la tiene parís que
será la sede en 2024 la capital japonesa
espera ahora el inicio de los juegos
paralímpicos entre críticas por los
récords de contagios registrados durante
este mes
andrew amaya no es amplia
último día de los juegos olímpicos de
tokio los mejores atletas del planeta
compitieron en una edición sui generis
marcada por la pandemia de kobe 19 tras
el final del evento los organizadores de
los olímpicos informaron que en total 19
atletas no participaron al haber dado
positivo en las pruebas de coronavirus
con su crimen ahora se toma porque está
me gustaría elogiar firmemente los
logros previos a los juegos de tokio de
estos 19 atletas hacer icono desde el
fondo de mi corazón les deseo lo mejor
en su carrera como deportistas en el
futuro quiero agradecerle a todos por
haber venido a japón muchas gracias
el número de contagios porque hoy 19
acumulados entre todas las personas
participantes en los olímpicos de tokio
fue de 430 personas tras sumarse 26
nuevos contagios el mismo día en que se
clausuró el evento
ahora que tokio se prepara para los
juegos paralímpicos que inician el
próximo 24 de agosto cuál es la
sensación que le ha dejado este evento a
los japoneses
estaba un poco preocupado pero al final
los juegos olímpicos' alegraron a japón
y al mundo
[Música]
después de la inauguración las nuevas
infecciones aumentaron por eso trato de
ser muy cuidadosa
este domingo los casos por correo en el
virus en tokio alcanzaron un récord por
cuarto día consecutivo con más de 15 mil
700 casos reportados el sábado
diferentes variantes del virus han
circulado en los últimos días en la
capital nipona y la propagación de dell
está altamente contagiosa se intensifica
en el país el gobierno mantendrá el
estado de emergencia por lo menos hasta
el comienzo de los paralímpicos y más
regiones se han sumado a la medida para
controlar la pandemia de kobe 19
con lágrimas en los ojos el futbolista
lionel messi se despidió en el camp nou
del que fue su club desde los 13 años el
argentino de 34 estuvo rodeado de sus
compañeros actuales y de figuras
icónicas del barça como xavi o puyol
messi aseguró que le hubiera gustado
despedirse del club con gente en las
gradas nuestra corresponsable en
barcelona-el es gas ángel con más
detalles
mes y dijo adiós al club que le vio
crecer donde llegó con sólo 13 años el
argentino se despidió en una rueda de
prensa debido a la pandemia tanto de la
afición que no le pudo ver como de sus
compañeros y ex compañeros de equipo que
se habían desplazado hasta el camp nou
para rendirle un último homenaje tras
esta carrera impresionante 21 años en el
club y 35 trofeos ganados la despedida
no fue la esperada y creo bastante
frustración tanto por parte del jugador
que admitió después echa de menos una
última ovación como por parte de la
afición y de hecho es centenares de
aficionados al barça se congregaron
frente al camp nou y nos decían pues
entender la voluntad de leo messi- de
seguir jugando aunque esto implique
probablemente según ellos que se vaya a
jugar al club parisino en la próxima
temporada una información que no quiso
confirmar messi dice que siguen abiertas
las negociaciones lo que está
seguro es que el mes y se va de
barcelona pero que messi volverá se lo
prometió a sus hijos que calificó de
catalán o argentinos y también dijo que
volvió a guiar porque barcelona es y
seguirá siendo su casa dejamos los
deportes y pasamos a otras noticias el
portavoz del talibán aseguró que el
gobierno afgano eligió declarar la
guerra y que no existe un acuerdo para
un cese al fuego en el país estas
declaraciones llegan cuando en las
últimas 24 horas el grupo ha capturado
tres nuevas capitales de provincia entre
ellas la ciudad clave norteña de kunduz
el ministro de interior de afganistán
aseguró que el gobierno está lanzando
una operación de limpieza en estas
ciudades que según sus palabras se
convertirán en las tumbas de los
insurgentes el país está ahora al borde
de una crisis humanitaria y la población
civil huye de los combates
esto es lo que queda de esta escuela
secundaria situada en la capital de la
provincia de helmand después de que
fuera alcanzada por los ataques aéreos
de las fuerzas gubernamentales afganas
que luchan por recuperar el control de
las cargas una localidad ahora en manos
de los talibanes el ataque aéreo se
produjo alrededor de las diez y media de
la noche los guardias me llamaron y me
dijeron que la escuela se había
incendiado que fuera allá a una clínica
cercana también quedó reducida a
escombros por el ataque los bombardeos
aéreos tuvieron como objetivo posiciones
talibanes matando a 50 combatientes
islamistas y dejando decenas de heridos
mientras tanto los funcionarios dicen
que hubo al menos un civil muerto los
fundamentalistas siguen ganando terreno
en el país este domingo capturaron tres
urbes entre ellas la importante ciudad
de kunduz capital de la provincia con el
mismo nombre que cayó tras los
enfrentamientos entre los talibanes y
las fuerzas de seguridad afganas horas
más tarde las ciudades de share pool ita
local quedaron en manos de los
combatientes este es el último golpe
para las fuerzas de seguridad que ya
habían perdido mucho terreno en los
últimos días desde el viernes otras
capitales de provincia han caído en
manos talibanes de berja ninja usan y
sharan capital de la provincia de nimroz
gran parte del campo ha caído en manos
del grupo islamista desde mayo cuando
las tropas extranjeras se fueron
washington su fin a que la retirada de
sus fuerzas fue la decisión correcta
después de 20 años de conflicto la
apatía de eeuu se completará justo antes
del aniversario número 20 de los
atentados delincuencia siempre
mientras los incendios en el norte de
atenas ya están más controlados la isla
griega de eubea sufre el embate de las
llamas por sexto día consecutivo más de
2500 personas han sido evacuadas de la
isla desde que comenzó el fuego que se
cree ha arrasado con más de 20 mil
hectáreas y que ha teñido el cielo de
naranja para luchar contra las llamas
grecia ha recibido ayuda de más de 10
países que se unieron con personal y
maquinaria a las labores de extinción
los expertos alertan de que si las
temperaturas siguen subiendo este
panorama podría ser cada vez más común
no es la primera vez que el mediterráneo
se enfrenta a fuertes incendios a pesar
de que los de este año no dejan de
preocupar a las autoridades locales los
más mortíferos fueron los del 2018 en
donde sólo en grecia murieron 100
personas sin embargo lo que más inquieta
es el aumento de las temperaturas en la
zona
grecia vive su peor ola de calor en más
de 30 años esta semana se registraron
temperaturas que sobrepasaron los 47
grados centígrados 10 más que el año
pasado en las mismas fechas
además julio fue el segundo más caliente
en la historia de toda europa
a julio de 2021 fue el tercer julio más
caluroso jamás medido a nivel mundial y
el segundo julio más caluroso en europa
los expertos advierten sobre las
posibles consecuencias de la alza de las
temperaturas en el empeoramiento de los
incendios a nivel mundial la tierra se
está calentando lo que significa que los
periodos de clima cálido serán más
intensos y frecuentes esto hace que el
agua se evapore más rápidamente lo que
seca la vegetación y aumenta el riesgo
de incendios forestales vemos que las
temporadas de incendios forestales se
están alargando y están siendo más
intensas en todo el mundo
otra particularidad que atraviesa la
región es la devastación de la
vegetación en estos sectores
600 miles de hectáreas creo que se han
quemado en el día y el peloponeso y los
incendios alrededor de atenas han
quemado parte realmente hermosas de los
bosques que han sido los pulmones de la
ciudad
según el sistema europeo de información
sobre incendios forestales 56 mil
hectáreas han sido devastadas en los
últimos 10 años mientras que entre 2008
y 2020 el promedio era de 1.700
hectáreas para el mismo período esto
hasta el momento sigan con más
información en france 24 punto com
[Música]